so in an interview natalie portman says  that when george lucas let them  improvise dialogue for attack of the  clones during the nebu scenes it got  inappropriate very quickly now i wish we  could see these scenes um but obviously  we probably won't end up seeing these  scenes but there's probably just anakin  and padme just flirting quite a lot so i  imagine quite a fun scene to be filming  but don't worry instead of this we did  get anakin saying i don't like sans so  so sometimes things happen for a reason  and we get far greater things but let me  know in the comment section below do you  wish we saw these scenes and what they  improvise or do you think it's fine of  what we got because potentially with the  improvise could have been more natural  but again there is a rating they have so  if it gets too inappropriate then  obviously can't show this and that is  what did happen to making a star wars  movie nothing more nothing less